-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Miley Cyrus and Pete Davidson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two of the best out there.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You two are hosting a live
New Year's Eve show on NBC.
It's called
"Miley's New Year's Eve Party."
Why did you decide to do
a New Year's Eve party?
-So, one thing I think that gets
focused on at New Year's time is
what's to come, being
optimistic, being hopeful
about all these things that
haven't happened yet,
that we have no proof
are going to happen.
And we kind of erase everything
that did happen
and we forget to honor it
and look backwards too
and look at the -- even these
last, you know, year and a half,
two years has been rough,
but there's these
micro moments of happiness
I'm sure all of us can find.
Mine was --
I'm recently an auntie.
So I have a little nephew now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that's great news.
-You know, even though this year
has been hard,
the last year and a half
you find those things that were
positive in the year before.
And you still are gonna look
forward to what hasn't happened
yet but I think just honoring
both sides of that.
So I wanted to bring
that approach.
And I also wanted to do
something that's obviously
traditional but I knew
that we would do it in a way
that is unique
and unconventional.
And we did that with
starting by going to Miami.
-So you're doing it from Miami?
-From Miami.
-That's going to be a party.
-I don't like to be cold.
That's why I'm in this.
I packed for your studio.
-Yes.
-And so that was
one of the things I thought
all these other shows, people
are going to have on big coats.
Everyone is going to be shaking
and freezing and then
I'm going to have no clothes on
per usual.
[ Laughter ]
He'll be funny
and I'll be naked,
and together, we got a show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
That's a promo right there.
-It's perfect.
-You've done Times Square before
on New Year's.
-Yes.
-I remember seeing you perform.
-So I had -- Yeah, I was
a little scarred from that
because this was in my day of
wearing the Hannah wig.
-Yeah.
-And it rained and then it was,
like, hailing and snowing,
and actually, you know,
like, when you've seen the --
like, a kid getting their tongue
stuck to the telephone pole
or something.
That happened but with my wig.
It got iced to my skin.
It got frozen to my head from it
being so cold outside.
-How did you get it off?
-I had to wait until it melted.
-Holy moly!
-My mom just was like...
[ Heavy breathing ]
...on my head until I could get
the wig off.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-Pete, how did you get
the [bleep] off your shoulder?
[ Laughter ]
-I went...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's interesting.
-That's not exactly
what happened.
-Miley, you're also overseeing
all the musical performances.
-Yes.
-Which I think you have,
like Questlove, have
a encyclopedic brain
when it comes to music.
-Yeah, we share
a lot of the same love
for the same artists too,
which is why I was so excited
to perform with the Roots,
but, yes, because I --
-You love music.
You know everything.
-I was telling you that I
actually have my Spotify --
You know, they tell you what
you've been listening to
throughout the year
and who you listen to the most.
It said that I listen to
97% more music
than the average user.
-Human.
-Yeah.
So I listen to a lot of music
all the time
and I'm just constantly
discovering.
But what's fun is to discover
something that's older
that I can kind of reinvent
and introduce to my audience
who wouldn't know
some of these songs.
So I'm -- That's one of the
things I'm most excited about is
this show is -- yes, it's kind
of a variety show
because there will be so much
variety and artistry
and I don't think one genre
is better or more genuine
than another.
I think that there's a space for
all of it
and I want to celebrate
and honor all of it.
-Mix it up.
-Yeah.
-Pete, last time you were
on our show, you told me
that you were taking
singing lessons.
-Ha!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you still taking
the lessons?
-Yeah, yeah, kind of, yeah.
-Yeah. And will you, maybe,
sing on New Year's Eve?
-Absolutely not. No.
[ Laughter ]
-Even by midnight?
Closer to midnight? No?
-Maybe, maybe.
-Alright, okay.
Alright, very good.
Pete Davidson, Miley Cyrus.